>> Ryan: 17 OFFENSIVE REBOUNDS
FOR DENVER.
28 POINTS, 18 REBOUNDS, 8
ASSISTS FOR JOKIC.
PAUL CAN'T HIT, ANOTHER CHANCE
HERE FOR THE NUGGETS, DOWN 14.
JOKIC PUTTING IT ON THE DECK,
LOST IT.
PHOENIX BALL.
JOKIC GOING NUTS, HE'S GOING TO
GET A "T."
>> Richard: I'M GOING TO BE
HONEST, I'M OKAY WITH THIS
TECHNICAL IN LAST SIX MINUTES.
YOU'RE NOT MVP IF YOU DON'T GET
A TECHNICAL THE NIGHT THAT YOU
RAISE THE TROPHY.
YOU CAN SEE THE EMOTION, THEY
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT THIS
GAME IS.
THESE FINAL SIX MINUTES WILL
DICTATE THE DENVER NUGGETS'
SEASON.
>> Ryan: PAUL SINKS THE FREE
THROW.
RICHARD, DO YOU THINK THERE WAS
A FOUL HERE?
>> Richard: WASN'T NO FOUL.
THAT WASN'T A FOUL.
>> Rya